picking up where we left off from
yesterday what we finished with was
thinking about rise over run in the
specific context where you have a curve
like this and it's great is tuned all
the time right so gradient like we
usually with straight lines who want to
jump in cylinder we say Oh gradient
we'll just call it in right because it's
just a number it's just a constant it's
not changing a small variable right but
here M is not gonna cut it it's not
gonna cut because in fact the gradient
is not a number smaller constant it is a
function itself but greedy is changing
wherever you look right so therefore we
replace this idea of the gradient as a
constant with the gradient as a function
in fact we call it the gradient function
right and rather than say rise over run
which is just kind of a nice and then
want equate ever and bring what crazy
news we said rise is really the change D
Delta the change in Y and not it is
really the change in X and that's where
we get this dy over DX notation from ok
now one word I didn't introduce
yesterday is that we call this thing not
just the gradient right but now that
it's a function it's it's own thing
we call it the derivative and derivative
you know it just means it comes from
something else right namely it comes
from the actual function right we let
this way of taking this rise over run
and putting on all these different
points and comparing out with limits
what was happening in a particular point
on there ok so this is the introduction
actual thing that we said was fit first
principles right we said f dash which is
just yet another way of indicating the
TEC notation right is equal to the limit
as H approaches you were off now what
was that numerator what was it
f off
f of X plus h and then we take away f of
X now just remember why do we do that
it's because f of X plus h is here and f
of X is here we just want the difference
all it is that's the rise and of course
there's that run do you remember when I
said to you in traditions topic the
worst thing that you can do is just get
get to work memorizing stuff and not
know where it comes from I remember
sitting next to you when I was in year
11 sitting next to people who just like
look it's just just memorize it okay
doesn't matter what any of it means okay
that's the quickest way to get on the
path of not actually understanding
what's happening this is rise right this
is run one last thing what difference
does that make if it weren't there that
limit as H approaches zero if it weren't
there it's not meaningless but what
would it be it be something else Mary it
had been the gradient of not that
another tangent the tangent all we want
right but if you've got two points that
are actually a part it'll be the secant
wantnt right it's not meaningless until
we started it's just not what we want
this is the grain of the tangent the
derivative
without that and many people like I have
to write this over and over again
without that it's the grating of the
second we're not after that okay so now
that's what we stopped right now I want
to apply it to a particular situation so
here's a function right now the one
we'll start with that you just want to
start with is just the problem x squared
if you see f of X right then you can use
this F dash X notation okay if on the
other hand all you see is this there is
no function called F right so none of
this really makes sense f dash what does
any of that in here you would have to
use this notation up here right if
you've got wise you just do one of the X
if you've got F's you use F and F dash
okay now I'm just going to come back
because for this example we're just on I
do actually want to go with a score to
make this a bit easier so this is f of X
okay let's proceed through this right if
f of X is that then f dash X is going to
equal 2 now it begins with justice
substitution if we know what F is I
should know what all those pieces are in
there
okay so we'll begin with the limit
because I'm interested in the tangent
and not the secant if f of X is x
squared then f of X plus h is X plus h
all swear you agreed that and there's f
of X just as we defined it we're
dividing through by H okay now what
we're about to do is what we call
evaluating the derivative evaluated
derivative from first principles this is
our starting point okay what we're
trying to do is manipulate this in such
a way such an I can actually put H
equals zero in there and see what
happens I can't do that right now
because H is on the denominator you
divide by zero it explodes okay so I
want to reshape this into something that
gets rid of H being just by itself on
the denominator so let's give this a go
obviously you look at the numerator
that's the only thing you can do
anything with here the numerator the
denominator is just super fine so I
write my limit because I want the
tangent not the secret you're gonna get
really sick of me saying that but I want
you to get in your head it's really
important to keep on saying on the
numerator perfect square when you expand
it you get x squared plus two HX plus h
squared and then there's that minus x
squared tacking along the end okay and
then of course everything is divided by
H right just because you're not doing
any work with them don't forget to write
this or the denominator they're still
there and they're still critically
important having expanded you can see I
can do something with this now can I go
next squared on the front minus x
squared on the back and they're going to
each other out okay now the reason why
this is good is because now I have a
common factor of H on the numerator
right common factor H let me take it out
we factorize it limit as H approaches
your because I've want the tangent not
the secret oh what's on the numerator H
outside off-page good we're still at
this still in H pain around there that's
all divided into three badge okay
fantastic
now I can cancel denominators go on yep
canceling out yes this is exactly right
I'm glad you raised that point why can I
get rid of this okay let me pull back to
you like this this okay now what's this
thing a little plot okay sorry yes now I
also ordered plug for say um what does
this thing look like even though it's
gonna make squared on the top because of
what you get on the bottom you're
actually gonna get a straight line
aren't you can you factorize X minus one
you can't with that so what does this
thing actually look like it looks like
this straight line with one difference
namely there's a hole there it's just a
hole right so X minus 1 here and X
equals the negative 1 is somewhere in
here I guess this method will hold it
okay so our problem is I can't simply
input x equals negative 1 because then
as you notice I am multiplying by here
and divided by zero and it loses me okay
however what I'm just come back to when
we define this idea of a limit right
what I try to think about is what am I
getting to was right and I'm actually
getting towards something real even
though I can't be there itself any more
than I can calculate the gradient of you
know a point to itself that's what this
is really doing rise over run as the two
points get close to get on right I
couldn't actually calculate that but I
can still see what it's approaching and
if it's approaching the same thing from
both angles then that's what that's
great I can take that as a meaningful
result okay so though a very good point
to mention because it's like yeah why
can I do that
and the answer is because it can't be
actually equal to zero so I can take it
out into the equation expression I say
now that I've done this this is the last
time I'm going to write the limit as H
approaches zero because I want say it
with me the tangent not the secret right
just like a hammer okay so now that I'm
there I've gotten rid of H on the
denominator right oh by the way H can be
on the denominator just not by itself
because when it's by itself the
denominator becomes zero as you say
Charlie
now I actually can say well let's just
see what happens when H is zero and the
answer is it's 2x plus zero
don't miss the plus zero it's not
trivial okay
just like multiply my one sometimes it's
not trivial adding zero is not trivial
because I see it comes from here and
that of course is just 2x
okay what's chain